speaking of robots titanfall wonderful
video game two can hash at the start of
the xbox one's life cycle while
relatively first couple of months at
least sort of the big you know first
exclusives on PC as well but first big
like you know console exclusive we've
been waiting for example and code to
show off something about their second
game apparently time to false old enough
that they will be making a second game
and for a bunch of platforms now coming
out on playstation 4 xbox one pc
probably not on wii u they didn't seem
sad but we'll see about that and yes
it's we're going to see more about it on
sunday june twelfth which is the sort of
EA's thingy a play they're doing because
they're not attending you three but what
we have seen so far is a very very short
teaser trailer where a Titan has a sword
yes Scottish guy narrating nourish no I
think he's New Zealand I went I really i
heard New Zealand accent they're easy to
our stray leaners in our Kiwi yeah you
guys weren't for Scottish Scottish what
do you think I felt the same yes gosh
Irish yeah yeah I'm Americans have
trouble with that one you know it oh
yeah it could be said African as well
who knows who no [ __ ] phones so fan
of the first time for Rob hella yeah uh
just that parkour system running around
with the shocky shoddy but hitting up
walls while running the whole tying
aspect was awesome first came to kind of
do that we saw a bunch of games since
obviously called a duties basically and
taking that that's a harsh yeah I'm
games like overwatch knee when I think
about it that's got a bunch of mantling
in there even the new doom has got some
sort of right and double jump mental
thing going on yeah the game was smooth
I mean halo 5 too yeah um game was
smooth I would say my only issues were
like the campaign at nature of it right
yeah this is kind of like a divisive II
thing where did you fall on that cuz
some people were happy that you know
they tried something new but other
people were like oh I wish I just had a
single player you know fleshed out
universe where did you fall on that rub
I just had a hard time following the
story because you're playing a
multiplayer match which is extremely
competitive typically my mind goes one
percent into that and to have a lot of
vo and
story-driven elements during like a
match just it felt it felt really
cluttered mm uh granted they had like
each opening of the match right had a
little bit of a cut scene which was cool
I'm news I give him like respect for
like trying something out you know like
it was a really interesting idea but
came down to it like yeah I feel like I
had to hit the web in order to find out
what the actual story was yeah in fact
now when you think back of what happened
in the story of titanfall can you put
you on the spot Mike what happened in
titanfall one remember once I was called
mercenaries yep was it maybe goodies and
baddies that's about it I do you
remember James McCallum yes so he is the
guy who in the teaser trailer for two it
seems to have his name on the side of
the the skate pot or whatever it is okay
bad but he died at the end of time fall
sorry okay which further like locked
himself inside the reactor and in the
last one right and the nuke went off
yeah I think Eric what Aaron did
actually surprisingly a pretty good
breakdown of that trailer which was so
short but yeah he basically says his
name on the on the drop odd that you see
and that kind of yeah as you said like
insinuates it's gonna be a prequel hmm
and even the fact that there are swords
almost I feel like with that there it is
look at that James become I mean it
doesn't doesn't necessarily mean that
it's his part either you never know they
might just be [ __ ] with us I'm but uh
why wouldn't it be I don't know cuz cuz
video game marketing sure cuz he knows
so they go gotcha so I wonder like it's
it would be it's like that mirrors edge
thing right it's like they bring it back
mirrors edge and then we're talking
about you know it being a reimagining of
the first game which is sort of strange
when you've only made one game and I
feel the same as the case for prequels I
feel like if you're gonna do a prequel
at least leave it's like the third game
it seems a little bit strange degree to
dive immediately back and in terms of
content for this game Mike do you think
the same thing we are we you are you
looking for a more flesh dead story sort
of titanfall experience yeah because I'm
with Rob I really like what they were
going for I like I don't think a single
player campaign is always necessary
because you're not rainbow succeeds
didn't have one and I still really like
that game there are a bunch that do that
you know overwatch doesn't have like a
traditional campaign but I've been
playing a ton of that
I it was mainly felt missing to me
because this was a new universe that
felt really appealing to me and wanted
to know more about it just from all the
trailer to saw it was weird to me that
they did that with the first game again
I I want to know more about that unlike
in the traditional sense I want to be
able to play by myself or with you know
like my friend and kind of go through
this well paced narrative that I didn't
get from like the kind of broken up
nature of the multiplayer campaign story
yeah my feeling about that was that
maybe you know respawn as we see the
titanium series sword there perhaps
respawn hada you know there wasn't he
was a new team was a small team maybe
the campaign multiplayer was just what
they could do with the resources that
were allowed to them though is that they
really had to build the framework for
that game and then you know hopefully
sell enough units so that they could
make a story mode because you know we're
talking about Vince Zampella here we're
talking about the co-creator of medal of
honor and call of duty which are series
that although we know them a lot for
multiplayer aspect like their
predominant like their have very good
single player commands in them like
throw at the entire series here you know
some of the most memorable first person
shooter scenes happened in those games
the early cod games and Beyond and I
thought wow line which frontline that
d-day scene showing my parents like get
low this like success yeah look so yeah
it was like that looks really good miss
storming the Reichstag and call of duty
one yeah did like the end of that game
like we talked about like mine warfare
of course the first miner warfare still
one of my favorite Google ignition and
the second one and it like just really
great stuff I'm wondering if they're
gonna throw all in on this one um
because I don't know like I there's this
new thing right where we have all these
games like destiny in the division and
and you know large-scale like games that
are games as services that are trying to
you know add to a lot you know even call
of duty sort of is doing that but on a
more yearly cycle so a little bit less
aggressively because they could just
sell a new game the next year I wonder
like titanfall never had that right
titanfall was kind of like evolve was a
game that sort of came and we're like
this is what we're doing and I was hot
for about two months and then sort of
like died off and it didn't really seem
like they were trying to make a game
which had a long longer tail than that
like it wasn't like they had this
massive DLC van they had bits and bobs
but they didn't have this huge like role
roadmap
yeah so like I'm wondering are they
trying to make here like destiny or
division or are they just like saying no
we're going to make this game is gonna
have a single player campaign in it it's
going on multiplayer you're gonna play
for a couple of months we're gonna sell
a bunch of them and then we'll make
another one again I hope that's what
they do I don't I I think you know like
destiny division those have their place
i hope that because the talent on that
team and also i don't know how much the
console launch factored into their
timeline last i'm sure that i'm assuming
they had to rush a little bit like to
get it out with it like within a few
months of the xbox one's release now
without that pressure and now with what
has been three years they've had to work
on this and you know like the wood
because the reception of it i would
assume that they would have more
resources just in terms of money and
team members but their disposals just
just two years it was two years that's
just march 2014 okay yeah and I I would
love to see them just focus on what they
did really well last time and kind of
you know improving upon that but Bob
Jones and a mexico point as well that
this is around the same time the
microsoft are really pushing me like
always online miss of the xbox one or at
least they had been pushing us prior to
the release of titanfall so having a
single player campaign was probably not
in line oh right necessarily oh wow yeah
so the online multiplayer campaign thing
was probably you know if we go back to
the metric else of xbox yeah yeah
synergize right what they were doing
it's maybe don't yeah they're free of
the shackles of that as well it'll be
interesting to see it in soon see if
they do cross-network play as well
because this is coming out of
playstation more as well as xbox one
yeah any were final thoughts on this one
rob excited first they're gonna show it
off on like we said the second week in
june during e3 e3 not during e3 i was
anything else you'd like to say would
you like like a small tight campaign and
then like new multiplayer modes did you
be happy playing the old multiplayer
modes again here's me co-op in it i
don't know i think it'd be called us to
have those separated more like I don't
know like replaying the maps for
campaign like that they felt so similar
rightly I was like I'm playing the same
map I might as well just play
multiplayer and go headstrong into that
eventually because I feel like and as
far as I was playing I remember like no
one eventually started playing campaign
that was a big problem he's like yeah
you just kind of I remember like trying
or having problem
joining exactly a campaign mission and I
yeah and then and then even like you've
even got jumbled were like you're
getting thrown around uh through
missions like I remember trying you
memory like you would try to start
campaign and you go into mission for
yeah yeah it was like why I have no idea
what is going on what is the timeline I
see everyone died yeah my mission not
and then there's like a whole you know
early state or early couple missions and
and then repeated then it kind of felt
like a cop-out like repeated all again
from the other side right CIA right it
was a little gimmicky but yeah I just
I'd like to see more separation because
I feel like in the office we like
definitely got a kick out of it yeah
we're having a lot of fun and then
unfortunately yet at the time of release
maybe was a little rough as well I don't
know hmm yeah kind of got over quick but
they'd have that real event game sort of
moment to the warrants though as cool as
the concept was it left a little bit to
be desired in terms of execution and
then I'm hoping if they do that again
maybe they can like tighten the hinges
on that to make that experience work but
I still really love to see a campaign
that I can really just dive into yeah
all right thank you both so much for
coming on talking to tan fall with us
we'll hear more about it on june twelfth
a ta play and if you're watching this on
demand let us know what you'd like in
plan 42 in the comments
you